Good morning Hank. It's Tuesday,
today's video is like Alice's Doc McStuffins Lego
It comes to you in only one part.
Part 1: The news.
I am of course referring Hank, to the El Chapo news
So a couple of weeks ago I got a text from my mother-in-law that said
"You need to read the El Chapo story in the Washington Post"
El Chapo, for those unfamiliar with his work, is the currently imprisoned alleged leader of the Sinaloa Drug Cartel,
and according to the Washington Post article in question, the world's most notorious drug lord.
He's known for his ruthlessness and daring prison escapes
and from everything I can gather he's like not the kind of person you want as an enemy
so I'm gonna tread pretty likely here Hank, because I am nothing if not a coward.
Right, so anyway I start reading the article, which details some concerns that El Chapo's lawyer has about
the conditions of El Chapo's imprisonment.
It's reported, for instance, that El Chapo is only allowed to watch one hour of television per day
and also that during his sixty-five days in the Juarez Prison,
he has only been allowed two intimate visits with a concubine.
The article also asserts that during his imprisonment, El Chapo has read two books:
the Spanish novel El Final del Ave Fenix by Martin Querol,
...and John Green's high school love story Paper Towns.
Now first off, I'd argue that Paper Towns isn't so much a love story as a learning
that romanticizing someone isn't the same thing as loving them story,
but yeah, apparently El Chapo has read one of my books.
which, y'know, is a little weird. I mean, I guess Paper Towns is about a larger than life character
who enjoys well-plotted escapes and has a bit of an empathy deficit, so maybe he found it relatable?
I have so many questions! Did he like the book? How was the Spanish translation? Did he ship Ben and Radar?
Did he emerge from the reading experience imagining Santa more complexly?
But the biggest question I have is like, HOW? How did a book I wrote eight years ago
end up in a prison in Juarez, Mexico?
Which led to an even larger question, I started to wonder how, like, ANYONE ever found my books.
You might be thinking, "Well, everyone else was reading them", or whatever
But in fact, that is not true! While my books have been far more widely read than I ever could've imagined,
more than 97% of Americans haven't read one.
So my readers are still in a relatively small club, Hank - it's just like, y'know, you, a few other people, EL CHAPO
In fact, at this point, reading ANY book is almost a counter-cultural activity
like a recent survey found that almost 30% of American adults read no books in the last year.
So, nerdfighters, no worries if you haven't read one of my books, but if you have,
I was wondering if you can share with me in comments how you came to read it.
Or I'd love to hear the story of any book that found its way to you
through strange and unexpected circumstances.
And yes, I am hoping to use these answers for inspiration in the coming months
as I work on my new story
Speaking of which, I should go back to that - Hank, I will see you on Friday.